Juan Hernandez is a former advisor to
the Mexican President Vicente Fox and he
joins us now one in what sense are these
people in the caravan asylum-seekers
well I've met with many of them I met
with them 7,200 caravan in the state of
Oaxaca that I now work for under the
governor Diego seen way specifically
working with immigrants mostly Mexican
immigrants living in the United States
but also it was my duty to make sure
that we treat in a humanitarian way
these 70-200 that went through one a
coatl and I'll tell you you sit down
with them for a minute and you're in
tears
these are children these are women let
me finish these are people looking for a
better way of life like your family and
my family did many years ago coming to
the United States well I didn't come as
an asylum seeker but if I was an asylum
seeker this caravan has marched across
to national frontiers it marched into
Guatemala illegally and then it marched
into Mexico illegally if you're an
asylum seeker aren't you supposed to
seek asylum in the first safe country
you come to my friend we all know the
United States is today the most powerful
nation in the world it's the dream of
many many people who are just trying to
get out of dire poverty violence to be
able to reach the United States and to
be able to to be a blessing as they are
the immigrants to this nation that's the
dream they're coming to the United
States and they're seeking asylum
they're not invading and it's such a
small number we're joined by ten twelve
thousand total my friend maybe you're
now saying that a dream is a basis for
an asylum I I might have a dream Utley I
might have a dream to live in Barbra
Streisand's house it doesn't mean I have
the right to go and move into her guest
bed but if but if you're in the block
away from her home and you're being
attacked and you're being raped and your
children are the only chance that they
will have is
to maybe join a gang and you can't even
feed them you would be knocking on that
movie star's home saying is there some
way that I could be here at your home
and work for you
yeah and she still wouldn't let me in
what you know that she would she would
my is the thing though you talk about
all the children there's women being
raped
these are overwhelmingly young men
what kind of refugees what kind of
asylum seekers leave the old and the
sick and their kids and their women folk
back in Guatemala or wherever and it's
just the young men who come across the
frontier it's overwhelmingly young men
and yes probably about 75 to 80 percent
are young men you're right they are the
ones back to our big dreams they are the
ones who want to do better for their
families and they're leaving desperately
they see no way that they can be able to
survive even in some of the places where
they don't know but just just everyone
with a dream the seven billion people on
the planet and as you say America is the
most powerful wealthiest all the rest of
it does that give six and a half billion
people the right to move to the United
States it's not that it's the right it
those many would claim that it is a
human right that if you are in dire dire
situation you're going to try even if
you have to break some administrative
rules what they have not committed
crimes what you're just seeking asylum
you're now part of the state government
in in Mexico yes probably what's wrong
with your state then if they just want a
better life why can't they move to your
state your state's better than Honduras
wherever they come from yes it is but
the dream for them was the United States
there's a wonderful article by Father
Melo a priest from Honduras and he
called it the boil over I suggest that
many of your viewers read it I think was
New York Times it came out the
translation and he he said that these
were a people they're not organized they
weren't paid by anyone a few dozens
we're going to desperately just leave
the country and it just boiled over
literally thousands said we can take it
no longer we must seek a better life and
it's happening you're right all over the
world today they're 250 million people
going from one country to another trying
to find a better life we have to deal
with it we must be a country of laws and
I'm speaking Mexico in the United States
but also countries that are going we're
being tested my friend today other
nations have not passed the test what we
need to pass this test of being
humanitarian my dignity to these people
why is it in the interests of other
countries for all their most talented
people to move to the United States or
Western Europe why is it in the why is
it in the interest of Guatemala or
anywhere else to be denuded of its most
talented people well sure it's mostly
economic in the United States if you and
I'm sure you do read the statistics
United States is growing less than 1%
the United States needs about 350,000
new people every year these 10,000 are
good people they get them they went
through our wonderful by the way is
doing great financially but their dream
is to come to the United States there's
plenty of good people if you go to these
Airport diners by the way you enter your
meal or they're on a machine
nobody needs people anymore it's all
automation one thank you thank you see
this is true 30% of the world's gonna be
unemployed in a few years